[Música]
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador afirma que se siente muy
bien a pesar de haber contraído cobit 19
por segunda vez el vídeo del mandatario
se difundió durante su rueda de prensa
diaria y en él hizo un llamado a la
calma
el gobierno de australia investiga si el
tenista serbio novak djokovic mintió al
decir que no había visitado ningún otro
país dos semanas antes de entrar a
melbourne y es que su vuelo partido
desde españa e hizo escala en dubai
tendremos reportes desde australia
la prisión de guantánamo cumple 20 años
de funcionamiento amnistía internacional
denuncia que allí las autoridades de
eeuu han torturado e incluso
desaparecido a varios reclusos
tendremos análisis en minutos
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
gusto saludarlos hoy y comenzamos esta
emisión en mexico porque el presidente
de ese país andrés manuel lópez obrador
afirmó que estaba muy bien un día
después de que se confirmó que tenía
cobit 19 por segunda vez el mandatario
grabó un vídeo para difundir en su rueda
de prensa diaria en el se le notó la voz
carrasposa y se tomó la temperatura y
también la oxigenación en sangre desde
el aislamiento de lópez obrador agregó
que tiene dolor de garganta y un poco de
dolor en el cuerpo esto fue lo que dijo
qué es lo que tengo
ardor en la garganta es como una gripe
con ronquera
un poquito de dolor de cuerpo al
principio
estoy tomando
paracetamol
y me siento bastante bien entonces
creo que
afortunadamente no vamos a necesitar
hospitalizarlos ni vamos a sufrir hasta
el 50 por ciento de los europeos
contraerá omicron en los próximos dos
meses si el ritmo de contagios se
mantienen según los datos de la
organización mundial de la salud
europa registró más de 7 millones de
nuevos casos de coronavirus en la
primera semana del 2022 esto es más del
doble que el promedio de las dos semanas
anteriores la o ms afirma que la
variante o micro ya está en 50 de los 53
países europeos y de asia central el
organismo agregó que la escala de
transmisión es tan alta que están
subiendo las hospitalizaciones en el
'viejo continente'
el tenista serbio novak djokovic
completó su segunda sesión de
entrenamiento para el abierto de
australia mientras espera la decisión
del ministro de inmigración australiano
alex court el podría cancelar la de
nuevo la visa a pesar de que un tribunal
falló a favor del deportista este lunes
ahora australia investiga si djokovic
mintió en su declaración de entrada para
asegurar que no había visitado ningún
tercer país dos semanas antes de su
ingreso a pesar de que su vuelo salió
desde españa e hizo escala en dubai
desde valmor nuestro corresponsal camilo
montoya tiene todos los detalles a pesar
del fallo del juez del circuito federal
de australia anthony kelly que le
devolvió a novak djokovic la libertad y
la posibilidad de disputar el abierto de
tenis el ministro federal de inmigración
álex todavía tiene el poder legal de
cancelar su visa y deportarlo también
puede prohibirle la entrada australia
hasta por tres años el gobierno informó
que está analizando el proceso los ojos
de la opinión pública ahora están
puestos en los documentos radicados por
la defensa de djokovic ante la corte y
en la veracidad de la información
entregada por el tenista puedes mentir
en formularios oficiales es una de las
causales que le permiten o cancelar su
vista de forma definitiva en las últimas
horas han surgido cuestionamientos sobre
el formulario de salud que todos los
viajeros desde el exterior deben
diligenciar para entrar en la pregunta
de si ha viajado o planea viajar en los
14 días previos a su viaje a australia
djokovic respondió que no varias
publicaciones en redes sociales que
están siendo analizadas presuntamente
evidenciaría en que el tenista durante
esos 14 días habría estado no solo en
españa desde donde salió su vuelo sino
que también en serbia su país natal
mientras tanto novak djokovic ha podido
entrenar en la cancha del bot leiber
taurina escenario un número uno del
torneo a través de un comunicado la
asociación de tenistas profesionales le
pidió a la organización tenis australia
claridad en los procedimientos de
ingreso al país y reveló que el 97 por
ciento de los tops jan que van a jugar
el torneo tienen la vacuna por ahora el
futuro de djokovic es incierto el torneo
empieza el próximo lunes pero todavía no
se ha dicho la última palabra
la vista sol y el presidente del
parlamento europeo falleció a los 65
años en la madrugada de este martes tras
más de dos semanas de permanecer en un
hospital en italia por complicaciones
tras una disfunción en su sistema
inmunitario solía había pasado más de
dos meses recuperándose tras contraer
una neumonía y el 26 de diciembre
ingresó de nuevo en un hospital por
complicaciones serias la asamblea
nacional de francia le rindió un
homenaje hoy a este periodista y
político italiano
y hoy hace 20 años comenzó a funcionar
la prisión de guantánamo ubicada en una
base naval estadounidense en el este de
cuba un nuevo informe de amnistía
internacional denuncia que los presos
que han pasado por allí han sido
torturados no han tenido asistencia
médica adecuada y tampoco un juicio con
todas las garantías eeuu ha utilizado
esa cárcel para las personas que ha
detenido en afganistán e irak luego de
los ataques del 11 de septiembre de 2001
para hablar de esto está con nosotros
desde washington reinó unido- blanca
hernández ella es portavoz de amnistía
internacional sobre eeuu señora
hernández bienvenida a france 24 y
gracias por este tiempo amnistía
internacional sostiene que dentro de
guantánamo las autoridades
estadounidenses han cometido crímenes
como torturas y desapariciones forzadas
en que se basan ustedes para decir esto
si van a ser buenas tardes
tenemos los testimonios de varios de los
ex presos que han estado recluidos en
guantánamo durante estos 20 años y
también hace unos años uno de los
comités del senado de eeuu en un informe
por desgracia todavía no ha publicado en
su
totalmente
han revelado muchas de estas alegaciones
de tortura que por desgracia no se han
investigado de manera plena pero sí que
hay muchas alegaciones y muchos indicios
de que hay diferentes detenidos han
sufrido diferentes tipos de tortura
entre ellos también desapariciones
forzadas
es decir no podían comunicarse con sus
familias no podían comunicarse con
abogados y ni siquiera podían decir
dónde estaban y cuando joe biden era
vicepresidente de eeuu en el 2009 el
prometió que iba a cerrar guantánamo que
ha hecho al respecto ahora que es el
presidente de eeuu
si este es un tema que llevamos muchos
años luchando para conseguir que por fin
se cierre el centro de detención de
guantánamo y es verdad que el presidente
obama prometió que cerraría la base de
intención y yo vaya porque pertenecía a
ese equipo que había tomado esa decisión
desde que bardem está en el gobierno y
lamentamos que solo un detenido
ha sido liberado y además no han
recuperado una figura que tuvieron
durante la época de obama era una
persona encargada especialmente de
llevar a cabo el proceso de cierre de la
base de detención 'tendremos que es una
cuestión complicada todavía quedan 39
personas allí dentro y requiere de
alguien que se encargue de liderar todo
este proceso porque requiere que esta
gente pueda salir de allí por fin
algunos de ellos recordemos que llevan
más de una década que el gobierno de
eeuu ha dicho que pueden marcharse pero
que todavía no han encontrado dónde
pueden ir o no está arreglado toda la
situación y por tanto si ya tienen gente
que han dicho que se pueden marchar de
allí y no han conseguido sacarlos
claramente necesita de un liderazgo
importante que ahora mismo el gobierno
de bailan no está poniendo y esto es una
de las cosas que les reclamamos y como
se menciona todavía quedan y nueve
presos en guantánamo brevemente en qué
condición están ellos
sí pues es complicado saber exactamente
cómo están porque el acceso es difícil
incluso para sus propios abogados no
siempre es sencillo y muchos de ellos
están a la espera de un juicio que es
ante comisión militar por tanto no
cumple con las garantías mínimas del
juicio puesto que incluso algunos de
ellos en catorce de ellos
van a quedar escrito de manera
indefinida y no sabemos nada de cuál va
a ser su futuro más allá que el gobierno
ha decidido que van a estar recluidos la
información que tenemos es poca pero
sabemos que en sus condiciones uno solo
como deberían ser entre otras cosas
porque no no están recibiendo las
garantías de un recluso de una prisión
está estándar gracias señora hernández
por este reporte y en otras noticias la
onu lanzó una convocatoria para recaudar
cinco mil millones de dólares en
asistencia para afganistán
el llamado lo lidera en el secretario
general adjunto de las naciones unidas
para asuntos humanitarios y también el
alto comisionado de la agencia de la onu
para los refugiados acnur su intención
es que con ese dinero se pueda ayudar a
22 millones de personas dentro de
afganistán y a 57 afganos que emigraron
a países vecinos
corea del norte lanzó hoy su segundo
misil en apenas seis días y reafirmó el
mensaje enviado en año nuevo por su
líder kim jong-un quien destacó la
necesidad de reforzar las defensas
nacionales tanto del ejército surcoreano
como las autoridades de japón
consideraron que el proyectil lanzado
por el gobierno norcoreano al mar de
japón es un misil balístico kim jong-un
ha insistido que es necesario expandir
su programa de armas nucleares
y así terminamos con nuestras noticias
pero ustedes esperen más en france 24
[Música]